we're going to start this press
conference just a moment we're going to
open up the mic here and follow this and
we'll get back to that story later here
we go
I'm Sheriff Greg Capers San Jacinto
County Sheriff's Office
with great news
the suspect is in custody I have just
left Montgomery County Jail where he was
taken and he has been magistrated he now
will be taken to my jail
and where his new residents will be
um
I would like to thank the men
behind me and the women behind me
they're not women here right now but
they everybody played a very very
integral part in the arrest and capture
of this coward
um
everybody behind me has worked
tirelessly
I know that there are several people out
of these 225 plus officers
and at this scene not to include the
millions of of people
thanks to the media y'all y'all push the
message out uh
but we've had calls from
Wyoming
Florida
South Texas North Texas Oklahoma
Maryland and those are just a few of the
places
we were here they were there
bottom line is we now have this man in
custody he was caught hiding
in a closet underneath some laundry
they would they effectively made the
arrest he is uninjured and he is
currently being taken to my facility in
Cold Springs
thank you
well it was a multi-jurisdictional
operation to say the least uh somebody
got a tip uh dpscid U.S Marshals FBI we
had attack team
they all meandered over there and uh
found found that that tip to be true
you know where he was that's unknown to
me uh maybe one of these guys behind me
can speak to the actual uh information
on on where how it was actually captured
what's your message family members the
surviving family members of those people
who were killed in this attack
well that they can rest easy now
um because he is behind bars and he will
live out his life Behind Bars
for killing those five
through the ASAC this is the ASAC
hey good evening thank you Sheriff
Capers my name is Jimmy Paul I'm an
assistant special agent charged with the
FBI Houston division
thanks for uh having me
so just wanted to say first and foremost
the the victims and their families are
in the Forefront of our minds and we're
extremely delighted that the suspect was
captured
the tip for the suspect's location came
in through the FBI's tip line
and we just want to thank the person who
had the courage and bravery to call in
the suspect's location
especially than Paul or Ted Williams Fox
News are you do you know if this
individual will be facing federal
charges uh currently it's an ongoing
investigation and he's being charged by
the San Jacinto County Sheriff's Office
that ongoing investigation I can't
comment on that at this point
hey guys we're gonna we're gonna let him
get through a statement in U.S Marshals
and efforts where we'll take questions
okay thank you I just wanted to thank
the person who had the courage to call
on the tip and also I'd like to thank
the many FBI personnel and local law
enforcement agencies who work non-stop
to bring this person to Justice to bring
a sense of
Justice to the victims and also a sense
of security to the community of the San
Jacinto County Community I mean this is
basically what we do you know we show up
we bring the adequate resources and then
we don't we don't let up we always said
it's not a matter of if but a matter of
when the suspects will be caught and
we're extremely glad that today was the
win at this time I'd like to turn it
over to the U.S Marshal service
representative
good evening my name is Joe Ruiz de
Chavez I'm a supervisory Deputy U.S
Marshal I oversee the Gulf Coast violent
offenders and fugitive task force here
in Houston Texas
first I want to say that this was an
atrocious crime that devastated this
community and this country
we received a call for request from
Sheriff Capers and we brought expertise
and fugitive investigations and
Personnel to assist in this
investigation the Marshall service is
the oldest federal law enforcement
agency
and we have an expertise in hunting
fugitives
this is a very sad time for the the
victims and I hope that this will bring
them some comfort
um
and they could grieve
thank you
because I had help from family members
or any other friends in the area to help
him hide for the last four days I can
say that we've contacted many families
Associates not only here in the Houston
area but across the country
I can't comment on that and did he ever
I can't comment on that who do they have
detained at the scene the female
detained at the scene who was that
again this is an ongoing investigation
we can't disclose that sure
removed from the country four times and
then in 2022 a protective order that was
filed by his wife domestic abuse
further investigation
office yes sir we actually filed charges
on him in 2022
and it to the best of my knowledge uh
they uh that we got a warrant for him
and uh
the Constable went to serve him in
another County because he he left here
and never could make contact with the
subject
um and uh then a few days later
the victim went to the District
Attorney's Office in our County and
filed a non-prosecution statement
the address where this arrest took place
have court documents that show that it
traces back to what an answer for the
best I believe
um is that still the case that this
would be a home of a family member
I can't uh I mean it it's really it's
still ongoing uh the investigation part
I wasn't part of the arrest team
for the shooting
happened once again not not that I know
of I I have no knowledge multiple
agencies was um DHS also involved was
vortac the agency who actually went hand
and made the apprehension uh they were
part of that team I do believe yes ma'am
that's still living at that home she is
currently an ice fugitive is anything
happening with her is she being
investigated are there follow-ups
happening with her I've understood from
deputies that she has been cooperating
and to my knowledge uh she is still
there because they the officers are
still there I have no direct knowledge
because this is this has all happened
within the last couple of hours but she
is still there
well you know made that person calling
this tip and will that money be going to
the person you called in that too
uh the money will be going to the the
person that called in to tip through the
proper channels uh yes ma'am I I I'm not
I'm thinking it's still 80 000.
um
we know that he's been in this country
since 2016 illegally meeting our peso
the question is and he had an AR-15
ready for that he was shooting the night
of this incident uh have you ever been
been able to connect the dots as to how
an illegal alien was able to purchase or
to uh get that uh AR-15 weapon
well I could just speak to conjecture
um buy it from somebody else on the
street are you conducting an
investigation to try to connect those
dots yes sir we are that that is an
ongoing investigation as well
for tonight's arrest
we would probably need to defer that to
the uh FBI or the U.S Marshals
sorry about that we received the tip at
5 15 pm and the arrest was made at 6 30
pm
discuss how surprising that you ended up
finding what appears on 15 miles away or
less
I can't really speak on that I can just
tell you that we're just extremely happy
that the citizen had the courage and The
Bravery to call in that tip
[Music]
I'm not sure if it was searched before
but we we immediately dispatched the
team out there as soon as we got the tip
we're gonna take three more questions
[Music]
foreign
we're obviously hearing that this was a
family's home that this person was found
so were other family home searched as
well was this one just a random tip what
happened
were there other families around
as far as we know this is our one-time
random tip but we've
contacted multiple houses and families
throughout the the area what is contact
right
males and other families we've done not
we've done knocking talks with with
multiple homes throughout the area and
we've gotten consent from the homeowners
to go in and take a look so we've done
done those kind of uh actions two more
questions
no ma'am nobody else is in custody of
the night and yeah I'm assuming that
they are still at the house questioning
the the people that were at the house
where the suspect was arrested
as far as we know we do not know anybody
else that was injured
yes yes sir
do you know what those are yet murder
five counts of murder five million
dollar Bond
no sir not at this time
say it one more time
I haven't I haven't had time to to visit
social media
to answer some of the Roundup questions
here I know that there are questions
very quickly